our Sony's new
wf-1000xm5 earbuds better than Apple's
airpods Pro 2. well today we will find
out because we are going to compare
everything from the design and comfort
microphone quality sound quality active
noise cancellation and more now Sony has
been on a roll they used to update these
a lot less often but now they are trying
to be competitive and this thing has a
redesign once again with a new kind of
build that's supposed to be more
comfortable now the case here seems
similar to the last one maybe it is
slightly smaller of course they have all
this recycled material and comparing to
the airpods Pro 2 it is a lot thicker
I'm talking about a lot you definitely
notice it a lot more when it's in your
pocket now as far as the size from the
front it is pretty similar the airpods
are a little bit taller but then
finishing that the Sony case is
noticeably lighter both have wireless
charging but the airpods supports
magsafe which is nice and Apple watch
Chargers so it's a little bit more
flexible and another difference is the
price tag the Sony's are 300 bucks
compared to 250 for the airpods but
right now you can get the airpods Pro 2
for 199 on Amazon we'll go ahead and
leave the link down below now as far as
battery life the earpods get about 30
hours with the case compared to 24 so
that is better but the buds themselves
the Sony's are rated for eight hours
compared to six and in the real world
they actually get more than eight so if
you like battery life that is amazing
now opening up the case these look
really cool I like that little
microphone Grille with that little color
and let's pull these out all right well
these definitely feel larger than the
air pods but of course you don't have
that stem that also takes up a little
bit of space now one thing you may have
noticed is that the Sony's have these
foam ear tips that are built in now of
course they give you a lot of options in
the Box just like the air pods but what
you're supposed to do is grab this
squish it down a little bit and then
insert it into here like that and then
the foam kind of expands and creates a
nice seal now I've actually bought foam
tips for airpods Pros in the past but
I'm surprised by how quickly this foam
expands and how comfortable it is it's a
lot better than the aftermarket ones I
got for the air pods but wearing these
now as far as comfort I still feel them
quite a bit more than these silicone
tips on the air pods and the buds
themselves also feel heavier as well so
as far as comfort at least from this
initial impression I would say the
airpods pros to win because they also
have that little vent that kind of
releases any pressure and it makes it
feel like you don't have sealed in
earbuds now as far as the controls these
stems make it so easy because you just
click or you can double click press and
hold to switch modes and it makes it so
simple with that you can also slide up
and down to change volume and I didn't
think I would use that in the past when
these came out but it's been very handy
now the Sony's on the other hand require
Taps so you can do a single double and
even four taps to adjust volume I think
that's crazy and it's definitely not as
convenient to be able to change stuff
now both of these have Quick Connect
functions uh the airpods they just work
with iPhone whereas with the Sony's you
have to have Android to get that
functionality but of course you can get
the app for iOS devices the earbuds are
registered here here so I just hit OK
and the cool thing is that the app gives
you a bunch of different settings
including different eqs and you can
customize it yourself which you can't
with the airpods now this is the
microphone quality of the new xm5
earbuds and Sony says that these have
amazing high quality microphones and
this is the microphone quality of
Apple's airpods Pro 2. you let me know
which one sounds better down in the
comment section below and else has the
active noise cancellation I'm going to
start out with the airpods Pro 2 and
switching to that right away all of our
HVAC noise goes away which is great now
I'm gonna pull these out and let's try
out the Sony's now right away I noticed
that even with active noise cancellation
turned off because of the foam tips most
of that noise is actually Gone without
even enabling the noise canceling but
let's turn that on and Bam right there
it just stepped it up another notch to
get rid of most of that sound but I can
actually hear the high frequency air
noise coming out of the vent more so
than with the air pods now I also have
an airplane Noise video right over here
to simulate that so we'll keep the
Sony's in let's turn this on
okay well I definitely hear the high
frequencies quite a bit let me toggle
this to off and then back on here
so it definitely helps to cut out extra
noise but I still hear more high
frequency sound than I would like to
let's go ahead and switch to the airpods
Pro 2 and I want to mention that Sony
said that they have a big improvement
with noise cancellation with these new
ones I'll start in the off mode
okay yeah these pass through way more
noise with both being off let's switch
noise canceling
okay
wow so I hear a little more of the low
end sound with the airpods but less of
the high frequency sound if I had to
choose which one I would prefer I would
probably say the airpod Pro 2 just
because it seems like it's a little
quieter overall uh but both of them do a
pretty good job now what I want to test
next is the ambient mode or transparency
modes because both of these have a new
mode where it'll actually switch between
uh both depending on what you're doing
the cool thing about the Sony's is that
if you have them in and then you start
talking it'll actually switch to the
ambient mode as Sony calls it and then
when you're done talking it'll go back
apple is going to add that here soon
let's turn that on okay Vadim go ahead
and say something hey man how do you
hear me to actually surprisingly good
yeah yeah how are you doing today I'm
all right how heavy is that camera
pretty heavy
wow I'm quite impressed with how that
sounds okay let's compare it to the king
in transparency mode bam that is on all
right but even say something all right
how do the airpods sound better do it
they sound better yeah the Sony sound
very natural but maybe just a little bit
quieter than reality whereas the airpods
sound insanely good almost like you're
not wearing anything but I would say for
maybe the first time ever this should
not be a deal breaker or something you
should even consider because these sound
incredibly good and now finally let's
compare the sound quality we're gonna
have three different tracks here
starting out with an EDM track the
classic Max Tech song and let's take a
listen
[Music]
now
okay
[Music]
wow
that was pretty impressive I would say
good base
uh the highs stand out I would say they
might even be a little bit sharper than
the air pods but more natural sounding
even the mids more I don't know just
more natural wow okay I was not
expecting that pretty cool so I would
give the win for this to the Sony's now
let's switch to our second track this
song is like a modern classic track with
instrumentals
oh
[Music]
foreign
very interesting I I want to say they
sound less fatiguing than the air pods
now they're not as loud so that could be
why but once again more natural
um the base actually is a little bit
better but the mids and highs sound a
little smoother of course you can go in
and you can EQ and you can adjust some
things you can kick up the highs a
little bit more
but wow these sound good and this one I
don't know if I want to say they sound
better they sound a little different but
if I was going to listen for a long time
I would choose the Sony's and then now
for our last track we actually had to
replace our rock song because now you
can't use that on YouTube unfortunately
this is call out by Thor a heavy fast
Rock track with a lot going on let's
take a listen
[Music]
sister
[Applause]
all right
well that's a hype song I want to like
go run around that these sound really
good my only issue with it and maybe can
get around it by going to the EQ and
like boosting all the frequencies up is
just that they don't get as loud as the
air pods and with airpods uh for this
one I actually turned it down a little
bit to be more equal as far as the
volumes
um and I feel like the vocals stand out
a little bit more here the bass is fast
Punchy they also sound maybe a little
bit more natural like I said before they
sound really good really really good uh
if they were as loud as the airpods then
I would be insanely happy but overall if
you care about sound quality well these
Sony's sound really good and I think
Apple needs to start stepping up a
little bit and release a newer
generation that has a little bit more
capabilities or maybe dual drivers
things like that they don't sound bad
but a lot of other earbuds are now
starting to beat them so with all of
that said are the new Sony's better than
the airpods well in a lot of ways yes
they do have some extra features a lot
of that some of the softer stuff I
didn't cover they're similar they have
upscaling as well they block out more
sound with that foam of course if you
have an iOS device the airpods give you
things like having Siri be able to read
out your messages having find my
capability which is awesome and once
again they are less expensive and you
can pick these up for 200 bucks now
using our link down below for Amazon
instead of three hundred dollars so
which one would I personally choose
it would be a very hard choice and I
know you're probably watching this video
because you're trying to decide I would
say if you really care about the iOS
features the Mac safe charging some of
those things more so than maybe sound
quality or better battery life for the
earbuds themselves get the air pods but
if you don't care about those things as
much you can spend a little bit more
money the Sony's are are really really
good option and if you're an Android
User I think it's a no-brainer to go for
the Sony's you guys let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below thank you guys for watching check
out one of those other great videos
right over there click above to
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
one
[Music]